So can say that from when computing the ILP.
We completely ignore false dependencies among data dependencies. And
only consider true or flaw or read after write data dependencies. So
ILP really only looks at those data dependencies but
there are two other types of dependencies in addition to data dependencies.
There are structural dependencies and control dependencies.
How do they affect ILP? And the answer is that first of all,
when looking at ILP, there are no structural dependencies.
Structural dependencies occur when we don't have enough hardware to do
things in the same cycle. When computing the ILP, we're assuming ideal hardware,
and as part of being ideal, it has no structural dependencies.
Meaning, any instruction that could possibly execute in the same cycle,
will execute in that cycle, and not have to wait. On some resource, like for
example, there being only one adder, so we can do only one add in a cycle.
We can assume that we have an infinite number of adders, so
if we want to do an add, we do it. For control dependencies,
we assume that we have perfect same-cycle branch prediction.
Meaning that branches. Are predicted in the same cycle in which we fetch them.
So we see all the correct instructions after the branch,
in the same cycle in which we see a branch. Let's see an example of this where
we have a program that has a flow dependence, and also an output dependence. And
then we have a branch that has a flow dependence. On R1 and
branches to label, if the condition is satisfied otherwise continues on.
And after the branch in the program you have,
an instruction, and at the label we have another instruction. So
now let's see how we compute isle B here, and these are again cycles. So
what happens is, in the first cycle we can definitely do this.
We cannot do the MUL in the first cycle, because it, it depends on the add.
So we will have to wait until the second cycle to do it. The branch can actually
not be done until the third cycle, because that's where we compare this.
Now let's say that this branch is actually taken. What we can assume is that.
Although the branch cannot execute until the third cycle from the beginning.
Since we started fetching the program, we know what the branch is going to do.
So we know that the branch is going to go to the label. And thus this
instruction, because it has no data dependencies on any other instruction, will
actually execute in the first cycle. Although it has a control dependencies. So
as you can see, not only are control dependencies not resulting in any delays
after the branch happens. Actually, we are assuming perfect branch prediction,.
And that means that this branch is predicted, even before it's executed, so
that we can just do depend on the instructions. Pretty much,
we can completely ignore Control Dependencies. The Branch acts as an instruction
that simply produces no results. So it eventually has to execute but
it has really no impact as far as the line Other Instructions is concerned. So
in this case, not only does the multiply instruction execute.
Even before the branch on which it has a controlled dependence executes.
Also the instructions at this MUL will feed values to who can execute before
the branch. So pretty much a branch itself might be delayed because
of true dependence. But it's control dependencies on that branch have absolutely
no impact on what the IP will be. Because we are assuming perfect branch
prediction where all the branches in the program are perfectly predicted.
In the same cycle. As soon as we begin fetching the program. And
from the beginning of the program, we knew exactly which instructions will
execute. So that we can just do them according to data dependencies